like about 40 years you were on the
streets for 40 years yeah 40.
but I started in Santa Ana and ended up
in
L.A
how'd you end up at Skid Row my brother
me being with my brother and he wanted
to have sex and I didn't want it how old
were you I was uh I was dirty in my 30s
Maybe
you're in your 30s
how do you know
I'm 71. wow
so in your 30s your brother wanted to
yeah well my my my uh oldest brother
raped me
and that continued when you were a kid
when I was about about 12 13 years old
so it's kind of in the family yeah
I went through a lot
growing up
I try to kill myself I couldn't do it
because I I love my mother too much
but to get through
the hard times in the abuse
it took a lot
I just thank God
that I'm here today
being on skip Road was an old piece of
cake
not knowing what was out there not
knowing
what people had on their mind
or what they're planning to do with you
is rape all kinds of stuff and that's
when I turned to drugs
just to keep my mind going and another
another place
to keep all the bad and everything away
but when I was off the drug it was still
there
those are drugs
cocaine correct correct yeah was it was
your father in your life when you were a
kid no he he was part of the abuse too
oh really
I thought my father was supposed to be
there to protect me instead he took
advantage of me
just like my brother
my mom was in the hospital for
tuberculosis for nine months
we had her away from us and that's when
the abuse with my brother started with
me
so it was almost like you had it in your
childhood you had it from yeah siblings
your parents yeah and then when I got
married my husband did the same thing
so
that's why I guess I
when I was out in the streets the
prostitution
just automatically yeah
I don't like the life I live but
it's something that I went through as a
kid and something that I continued doing
as a an adult
if I can go back and start all over none
of this would
oh none of this would have happened what
would you have done differently
I would have found help from somebody
and go from there but back then it
probably wasn't as much help as there is
now no
and then at back then you couldn't open
up and say things like this
you know it only not only happened to me
it happened to my sister too
that I found out after she passed away
yeah being out here in eating fun that's
when I started doing drugs and selling
my body I didn't care no more
I didn't trust no man I thought they
were all the same
and finally I met somebody
and I've been with him for about eight
years
and the only thing we have
to do with any Sex Is We Kiss no sex at
all from the eight years we've been
together
and I trusted him he took me for the
person that I am
not a piece of meat that he can give to
take advantage of
no he was different from all the rest of
them but I thought all the men that
walked into my life was going to do the
same thing that I went through when I
was young
how do you think your four decades on
Skid Row have changed you
it right and
I've seen a lot
I grew up fast a lot faster I was aware
of a lot of things
um
it was hard but it made my life easy
to our
the things that I went through
weren't as bad as the the things that I
went through out in the street weren't
as bad as the ones that I went through
when I was young so I was able to cope
with the the
violence
the drugs the prostitution it just
brightened my uh been me up a lot
you know and then that's when I started
taking girls that ran away from
different places underneath my wings
and there's one that she was a heroin
addict
whoop knows her
um
I took her underneath my wings and she
has her mother her mom passed away
she looked at me as her mom and so she
was a big part of my life I don't have
no kids
I took a lot of women a lot of girls
underneath my wings and took care of
them and um not let them go through the
things that I went through on the
streets hoping that
them being out there they don't have to
go into prostitution and that well a
couple of them did
I couldn't do nothing to take care of
their heroin addict uh addiction
but um
yeah I came from a family from 16
sisters and five brothers
and it's me and my sister are the only
two living out of 21 kids you're kidding
mm-hmm
how did everyone else pass away I mean
at some old age cancer
uh natural death
and I'm the fourth to the youngest but
not not too many with drugs
not too many involved in drugs
uh would you believe it all of them all
of them all of them are said for two oh
wow
all of them but chapter two
I just lost my baby sister
in Albuquerque
a hit and run and I didn't know she was
dead and I was looking for her for a
whole year and they had her in the
morgue
sorry
foreign
that a homeless to go through the stuff
that I went through
or who knows what they're going through
I don't know
but who's been in my life
he knows
he was a little
he he was a
how can you say it intimidate he used to
intimidate me and my daughter a lot he
intimidates everybody
but I ain't scared of him no more back
then I was I beat the hell out of him
I ain't scared of him no more
he's my right hand down here he's good
people now
I think I trained him
hey you're doing a good job yeah he's
good he's a good dude yeah he's honest
before if you would have known him
before you would have looked at him and
say man what a bully you know somebody
needs to beat the [__] out of them
I picked the right guy
he's good people I love him what are you
afraid of what do you worry about
God
I ain't worried scared about nobody
not no more you be out in the streets
you know
I've been
with gang bangers I've been with uh the
blood I had I have a old man I've been
with the Grape Street have you ever
heard of him I've been with great
um Crips even all different sides
yeah
they're all down here yep
this is where I met him mosquitoes like
a mix like everyone Blends here yep you
know whereas in other neighborhoods
they're all separate yeah you can't mix
up you can't mix it up here it's here
right here you can
yeah yeah Skid Row is pretty unique how
how has it changed over the four years
40 years oh man it changed a lot the
streets used to be real bad now there's
empty
them from
from 7th to 6th Street on San Pedro
I mean there was people tents people
just all day long 24 7 Up and the drugs
you know we were all up going back and
forth doing our thing now it's cleaned
up it's not like it used to be it's
scheduled used to be uh tents on both
sides garbage all on the streets and
stuff and they cleaned it up a lot of
people have housing now yep even when
you get in housing they're so used to
being out in the street they come they
end up back out like me right now I'm in
the place and I'm blessed you finally
got housing I finally got housing God
blessed me how many years were you on
the streets
I was on the street for 40 years really
yeah in a tent uh in the tent up and on
I'd sleep on a sidewalk without a tent
it's rough
yeah
you know we had cold nights and rainy
nights but the midnight helped us a lot
too because we stayed on the courtyard
and if it rained we stayed inside uh a
place they call safe sleep
some of the craziest stuff you've seen
on Skid Row
oh
you've seen people get murdered I know
that I I've seen people get killed
I've seen a lot of my friends die found
them dead in their tent
um I seen
um a young girl
getting
um
beat handcuffed
and had made her eat her own [__]
I've seen um
I've been myself I was taken off the
streets
in this truck and this I thought I told
the guy what I thought he wanted a date
he was so damn [__] up on crack
that he took me for a ride and I thought
I was never going to come back I swear I
thought my life was over
the people out there you can't it's hard
to trust anybody you had to
blend yourself in then you have to get
to live the way they are you have to
know the way they run the you know it's
it's not easy it's not easy at all not
easy especially for a woman yeah a
woman's bad because that's hey
they see a piece of meat they take you
and they start working you on the
streets and stuff now here you have a
sugar daddy
then you have uh a pimp
the drugs have changed too the drugs
yeah now they've got the fentanyl you
don't know what's in the crystal meth
or the crack oh the crack
if you know the right people
because I used to uh back in the days I
used to make crystal
the drug is not nothing like back then
now you can't trust to take anything
that's when you should come out clean
the people keeps on taking it are you
still smoking crack I'm gonna be honest
once in a while yeah
once in a while not like I used to
because I'm not out in the street
what was the most out of control your
life ever got oh when I was out there in
prostitution
I've seen a lot of days and a lot of
nights that I thought I was going to
come back
the People You Meet it's not what you
see on the outside you don't know what's
on the inside
they can be somebody real nice and you
look at them you can trust them but
they're evil as hell in the inside
you made a mistake I've seen a lot of
women go through that [__]
what's your biggest regret
prostitution yeah anything else I can
handle
it's a prostitution
did she might from my family to look
back and see what I put myself through
but it is what it is
what is prostitution do to a woman
what does a prostitution do to a woman
well what it did to me
it made me go no I went out there and
did what I did to make money for my
drugs and to survive on
um
but I find myself doing it and doing and
doing it I regret
putting myself because everybody knows
me out here
everybody knows me
and I think the cops know me too but to
put myself out here like I did
and if you would have seen the person
that I was before all this happened you
wouldn't even think that I would have
put myself through any other [__]
I was born and raised in Redondo Beach
I had a family I had a husband
I had a home
what happened what happened that you
ended up in this situation what happened
that you ended up here
because me and my husband split up
um
I ended up staying with a friend
then
my brother told me to for me to get off
the streets he works at night I would be
by myself during the um I would be by
myself at night
and then during the day I'll be out
it didn't work out like that so I came
live with him my goddaughter brought me
over
and I came to live with him I got things
all right doing okay then it just
started getting worse he started buying
me the drugs and make it easy for see if
I would end up with him
hmm
and from there he put me out of the
street he goes
get your stuff
you can go out there and live with all
the rest of them so I did luckily I
found I ended up bumping into this girl
uh Miss black chick that took me under
her wings
and she was younger than me because she
already knew the streets
and told me as long as I'm with her
nothing will happen to me and I'll get
through this
and look at I got through this and she
passed away
a lot of my friends that I met out here
that helped me are no longer here
so now I got me a place
I'm happy where I'm at
but still it's hard because I want to be
out here out in the street again
honestly it's addictive isn't it oh yeah
I'm in there I got everything everything
I moved in I had TV Furniture I have
everything you got a bed I got a bed
everything
and I got my three dogs their small uh
mixed Terriers
but they I go to psychiatrists and um
without all this [__] that happened to
me growing up and stuff I'm seeing two
psychiatrists
and um they gave me papers for motion
support my dogs if they weren't in my
life I don't know what I'd do
but being in the apartment I'm happy and
everything I got running water a
bathroom I got kitchen I got
refrigerator I can cook every day things
that I couldn't even do out there
and I find myself sitting there wanting
to go back out in the streets again it's
crazy
I can't do that
I don't know it's a phase that we go
through or what but
I didn't know a lot of people that got
in their place and ended up back out in
the street yeah they get a free
apartment
and they still run out to the streets no
we pay for our apartment well you have
to pay for it yeah but a lot of people
are getting it for next to nothing yeah
they're getting it for 45 I have to pay
321 dollars for mine
then my boyfriend he stays with me and
he has to pay 300 so that's uh 642
dollars we paid
but I'm head of household first time in
my life I had a receipt underneath my
name rent receipt
what do you think the problem is with
all these people on Skid Row why do you
why do you think there are so many
people that are homeless drugs
yeah but there's there's something
deeper than that
uh going wrong in the house right but I
think when you boil it down to what it
to its Essence I think it's
a lot of parents just aren't willing to
truly love their kids I know that's what
it says it has to do in the house the
parents don't care what their kids are
you know back in the days it was
different you know now
um with the kids now
they take off the parents ain't gonna go
look for them
the only interest that they have is when
they pass away I mean the cost of living
is so high so a lot of parents are
struggling to just make ends meet but in
school they're not even teaching like
they're teaching algebra and
trigonometry and all this crazy stuff
they should be teaching people how to
love each other
oh I didn't I couldn't read or write and
still can't a little very little
so they passed me just to get me to
school but um
other than that
I grew up with a hard life my mom
did watching and ironing for people
um my dad worked as a janitor and uh
Harvard General Hospital in Torrance
um I grew up with Tammy Downs
uh the state sent us little brown boots
like Little House on the Prairie
the and two dresses and a couple pairs
of underwears and compare socks every
year
so I wasn't brought up with brand new
stuff
the only time I ever got brand new stuff
is when
I got married and my husband you know
and that what would you say is the most
important
uh lesson you've learned
how to love other people how to be nice
and kind
and be there in case anyone or anybody
needs you
there's a lot of people out there you
can't go to him because they're not nice
at all they're out there
for other reasons not me I went through
it I know how
I what I had to do and where I ended up
going and I'm just I'm out there in case
anybody needs me to give him my kindness
and the love that I got
that's wonderful because everybody knows
me for that
that I
love each and every one of the people
out there no matter who you are or what
you've done it helps to understand yeah
what people might have gone through even
if you don't know the details yeah just
just imagine they probably went through
something similar to maybe what you mean
they need somebody that that cares and
is going to sit down and listen to them
and I'm one of them
I got enough problems of my own but I'll
put them aside just to listen to
somebody else's that's great
all right Annette thank you so much for
sharing your story